this video is sponsored by War Thunder
in the year 2000 archaeologist Mark Abby
was working at an excavation in the
ancient Greek city of aphrodisias
thousands of sculpture fragments were
recovered and delivered to
archaeological Depots pending their
exhibition in museums these statues they
dug up were Pure White and aesthetic
that continues to inspire our modern
architectural and Artistic Styles to
this day decades later Mark Abby visited
one of the archaeological Depots and
upon examining the statues closer he was
shocked to find spots of color on them
red pigment or lips black pigment on
hair gilding or limbs this discovery put
classical statues and architecture in a
completely new light could it be that we
were completely wrong about our
perception of the classical era worse
apparently archiona just a museum
curators have been scrubbing off this
paint residue from statues and
Architectural elements before presenting
them to the public in this New Yorker
article Abby is quoted as follows
imagine you've got an intact lower body
of a nude male statue lying dead on the
Depot floor covered in dust you look at
it up close and you realize the whole
thing is covered in bits of gold leaf oh
my God the visual appearance of these
things was just totally different from
what seen in the standard textbooks
which had only black and white plates in
any case this was a sensational
Discovery it turns out that our
perception of classical art and
architecture was indeed completely and
utterly wrong researchers got to work to
correct this historical misunderstanding
and when they published their findings
everyone celebrated them in the work
they did thank you for watching uh no
wait I'm sorry I mean they started
getting death threats from the far right
what's going on here why did this
seemingly innocent Discovery cause such
an uproar let's find out ancient statues
first started getting excavated on a
large scale in the Renaissance Era when
there was a great Revival in interest
towards everything classical there was
also a newfound scientific drive to
label and categorize everything
additionally there was the transatlantic
slave trade the intersection of these
three things produced a bizarre Vortex
ancient statues and architecture got
sucked into and we continue to suffer
the consequences to this day and so if
we consider oh sorry about the noise
there is a battle going on courtesy of
War Thunder this sponsored of today's
video War Thunder brings the most robust
all-encompassing vehicle combat ever
featuring more than 2 000 tanks playing
helicopter turns and ships in online
player versus player combined arms
battles the vehicle roster spends more
than 100 years from the 1920s all the
way to present-day modern vehicles each
of them is detailed perfectly down to
the last bolt which provides for fun and
immersive gameplay instead of
traditional hit points the vehicles use
Dynamic damage models meaning they take
damage on their specific components or
crew members which determines whether
you survive a hit or not upon damage or
destruction a damage x-ray will show you
exactly what happened to your vehicle my
favorite class of vehicles is anti-air
nice jet you got there what a handsome
helicopter have I shown you my anti-air
missiles I really appreciate how ground
units can actually fight back against
the aerial threats it adds another
welcome layer of complexity to the game
also the fire and explosion effects are
just pretty damn good War Thunder is
available for free on PC Xbox and
Playstation both on the latest and
previous console Generations use my link
in the description to start playing and
get a large free bonus pack of multiple
premium Vehicles a premium account
boosters and more thank you for checking
out War Thunder they support me making
more content for you now back to the
video so what hell is up with this color
business how do we go from an intriguing
archaeological Discovery to Neo-Nazi
death threats to understand what
happened we need to go forward in time
the year is 3023 centuries after the
climate catastrophe archaeologists are
Excavating the ruins of Western
Civilization when they make a
sensational Discovery they honor the
remains of an ancient DVD store where
they find a well-preserved piece of
disk-based media according to linguists
the title refers to some sort of ruler
of finger-based jewelry miraculously the
video is mostly intact though there is
no sound this causes a global sensation
as the Society of 3023 happens to be
going through a western civilization
Revival period where they ReDiscover old
western culture and incorporate aspects
of it into their own they are also
strangely obsessed with height and
considered tall people to be inherently
Superior to short people work begins to
decipher the meaning of this dispaced
media after months of studies and
Analysis researchers present their
conclusion this ancient piece of media
is about the superiority of tall people
obviously right he grew of short people
set out on a quest where they constantly
need the help of tall people as the
short people bumble around the landscape
helpless and Tiny they told people wage
all the important civilizational battles
in the background they also discovered
the ruins of a short civilization in the
mountains having been decimated by
Superior tall adversaries though the
short people do win in the end Scholars
associate this unexpected twist with the
growing self-hatred of Western tall
people in the time period it is commonly
understood that Western Civilization
fell due to the importing of short
people from abroad in this area of
decline tall and short people were
allowed to marry producing inferior
Offspring movements associated with
height Pride became frowned upon and
told people increasingly suffered from
Hyatt guilt this ultimately doomed
Western Civilization as the inferior
short people were allowed to infiltrate
centers of power they mismanaged the
government causing it to falter and then
collapse thankfully the civilization of
3023 had embraced height Supremacy in
time before history could repeat itself
what you've just listened to was an
example of misrepresenting the cultural
products of a past era to suit
contemporary ideological needs it's a
way of fortifying the past in service of
the present whether deliberate or
accidental which is exactly what
happened with ancient buildings and
statues see thinkers of the Renaissance
period had some relevant ideological
problems discrepancies they couldn't
quite resolve such as humans are
supposed to be the highest form of life
the crown jewel of God's creation and
yet we're selling our fellow humans into
slavery and working them to death in the
colonies for a profit how do these two
things fit together they don't right
it's either one or the other or so
people thought until the emergence of
scientific racism born at the
intersection of the slave trade the
drive to label and categorize things and
the new interest in the classical
scientific racism breached the
aforementioned contradiction turns out
once they arbitrarily categorize black
people as inherently inferior twides
suddenly it's more acceptable even
preferable to keep them as slaves we're
not committing a porn Crimes by debasing
God's Crown achievement oh no no no no
we're sponsoring the backwards blacks
lifting them up from their primitive
ways and giving them upper civilized
work in the Americas so really they
should thank us for what we do to them
this sounds completely ludicrous but
this was the actual Christian
justification used to condone slavery
and this is where classical architecture
and statues came into play whiteness was
and in many cases still is associated
with positive attributes Purity nobility
Grace elegance civilizeness and so on
and oh would you look at that this past
era of greatness is of that same color
importantly we white Europeans are also
of the same color moreover our facial
proportions are closer to the ideal
depicted by the statues while blacks are
farther away from it meaning we are the
superior ones and this does sound silly
when spelled out like that but that's
racism for you from that point on the
white statues and buildings weren't just
intriguing artifactory past era they
became mascots of white supremacy and
tools for justifying racism and there is
a rich literature out there from the era
detailing the racial hierarchy with
statues as the gold standard this
hierarchy went ancient statues
Caucasians Asians and Mongols black
Africans monkeys and then dogs yeah so
alright statues became symbols of white
supremacy isn't this conclusion a bit
far-fetched though and not really if
you've ever encountered white
nationalists in your life you might have
noticed them using the white statues as
their symbols that's no accident
identity Europa an openly white
supremacist movement particularly likes
using them in their promotional material
and if you visit online circles where
white supremacists are present you'll
notice quite a few white statue profile
pictures and Forum avatars so yes as we
can see white statues and the perceived
whiteness of the classical era became
part of the identity of modern white
supremacists so when Sarah E Bond
professor at the University of Iowa
published an essay about the ancient era
actually being quite colorful she
started receiving a flurry of death
threats from White supremacists now
alright I'm not a Nazi you might say but
I still like the blank statues better
they look more Majestic and elaborate
whereas many of the colorful statues
look outright cheap and that's fair
enough we all have different tastes in
some cases where we don't have enough
paint residue on the Statue we cannot
fully replicate the layers leading to
very basic colorings without too many
details or shading sure but consider
this those statues for the most part are
not not contemporary art pieces they are
historical art pieces and the primary
reason we look at historical art pieces
is not to look at beautiful things but
to look at history and if history means
colorful statues then I want to see
colorful statues not our whitewashed
falsified idea of them case in point I'm
sure many people would prefer the Mona
Lisa half naked but that's no reason to
put tits on her is it because that would
be a falsification of the original so if
a historical art piece also happens to
be beautiful to the Contemporary
Observer that's just a bonus really the
main objective remains historical
accuracy imagine if someone took a
prehistoric cave painting and started
erasing the parts they didn't like to
make it look nicer or just remember
those failed Spanish immature
restoration attempts I'm sure the M
Artisans thought that the Saint George
statue would look nicer with that color
scheme but thankfully in the end actual
professionals restored the statue to its
original colors and there was also the
famous monkey Christ and that feature
alcohol syndrome Mary as ridiculous as
these look they are no different from
what they did to classical statues when
we scratched the paint off them it's a
hand-fisted crude attempt to fix them
while in reality do doing nothing but
reading the original and thereby
falsifying history I personally prefer
the colorful statues because if they are
fully replicated they look simply
awesome and even if they aren't at least
it's as close to the original as
possible that way we can gain a real
window into the classical era not some
whitewashed make-believe
invented by 17th century pro-slavery
eugenicists but this false idea of a
pure white classical era got stuck in
our culture and it ended up producing
some highly symbolic and famous
buildings that are based on a complete
misunderstanding of said era for example
take a look at this picture I took at
the Museum it's a funeral urn and as you
can see it's painted and there is also
the ancient equivalent of graffiti on it
and here I don't want to let Hollywood
off the hook either they too contribute
to the whitewashing of the classical era
though I doubt it on purpose they are
the same victims of this false
perception as the rest of us as a side
note they do the same thing with the
Medieval Era so instead of the colorful
buildings clothing and so on we have
everything dark washed out muddy and
covered in all this to say we could
seriously use some historical
Readjustment but today we have gotten to
the point or rather the global far right
has gotten to the point where if someone
suggested restoring ancient statues as
best as we can to their original colors
it would be denounced as woke nonsense
degenerate Creations meant to groom
children to LGBT ideology with their
aggressive colors or something and don't
believe me or at the point where a black
kid playing Charlie in the Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory musical is woke
apparently we really are in a Vortex of
far out psychosis after Bud Light didn't
end with a trans woman we had heroic
anti-woke Warriors destroying video at
the local supermarket which ended up
being their own brand of beer
we got Kanye West becoming Trump
supporter and then declared death
country or Jews I could sit here all day
and list off all the bizarre things
prominent conservatives have been up to
just in the last few months but I think
we can all agree that this isn't normal
this is absolutely deranged to the
average person all of this is psychotic
and since they're going this far into
Crazy Land it's not hard to see that if
we try to correct our perceptions of the
ancient era they would go absolutely
ballistic so far only the neon artists
did so but just wait until Mega
Republicans discovered this issue and
turn it into another goddamn culture War
talking point because apparently
everything has to be culture War
nowadays well except for War Thunder
which isn't culture War yet I mean can
you imagine ah your main helicopters
that's woke quick reminder use my link
in the description to start playing to
get a large free bonus pack and join the
fight but if you bring out a plane or a
helicopter I will nail you so keep that
in mind so then those of us who aren't
affected by this deranged anti-woke
culture War psychosis can just go to a
museum and appreciate the artistic
choices of people from the classical era
like normal people do thank you for
watching long time viewers might note
that this is the second remake of my
original video about statues the first
remake was just a graphical update of
the original video but I wasn't happy
with the script itself I left too much
space for the but I like statues with
that the color is better argument which
this newest version has hopefully
addressed and I can't wait for all the
intelligent insightful emails I'm going
to get once I publish this video thank
you for watching once again and if you
like my content please consider
supporting me on patreon and I'll be
seeing you next time
[Music]